brady i want to tell you about a lovely
puzzle
that was invented by two undergraduates
at michigan state they call it the
stepping stones puzzle and it goes like
this you've got a chess board it's
infinite and you've got a certain number
of brown stones
that are worth one point each
the puzzle is you can put down the brown
stones anywhere you want so you've got
four brown stones that's fixed you put
down your four brown stones and then you
add the white stones the white stones
are numbered two three four five six
there's one of each value and you can
only put down
a stone label two
if the sum of its eight neighbors the
sum of the eight neighbors of that
square is 2. well you can put a 2 here
because it's got 2 neighboring squares
of value 1 and 1 plus 1 is 2. so 2 is
legal and having put the 2 there we
could if we wanted put a 3 here because
there's a 1 and a two we could have put
two here also instead of putting it
there we could not have put it here
because the sum of these
stones around it namely this this and
this are three so we could only put a
three there but we can't put a three
there until we've placed the two stone
we've got to place the stones in order
and the puzzle is for a given number of
brown stones that you start with like
here's four how many white stones can
you put down what's the highest number
you can get to
so let me do it with two two browns two
browns exactly we're gonna do it with
two browns and we're going to work out
if n is one you can't do anything you
can only get one so the answer i'll call
it a of n if n is two how many how far
can we get well let's try it i'm going
to start off by putting the two brown
stones worth one point each put them
there and now there's a unique place to
get it to place the two which is between
them i can put it there because one plus
one is two now
i can put down the three and i could put
the three i could put it there or there
or there or there but without loss of
generality as we say i will put it there
so now we have to find a place to put
the four
well i could put it here because the one
and three makes four but it's a little
better to put the four here because then
this frees up
this square for the five we've got to
put the 5 somewhere we've got to make a
place for the 5. so i'm going to put the
5 there and it's legal because it's got
2 neighbors 1 and 4. now what about the
6 well there's a choice we could put the
6 here no no i can't put it there
because that's got neighbor five four
and one i could only put a 10 there
you've got to put them in order yes
you've got to build your way up so it's
not what's the highest value can i get
on the board it's what's the highest
value i can get on the board building in
order building an order yes
it's like climbing a mountain you've got
to get work your way up oh i can see
where you can put a six
here right yeah
yeah
all right
six it's legal because we've got a one a
two and a three it makes a six we could
have put it there too but i i like
putting it here does that not now
invalidate the three the three
remains valid the three main remains
valid because when it was built its
neighbors added up to three and and
that's fine yeah and then we can use it
to build up other things yes all right
seven where are we going to put seven
i'd like to put the seven here
because it's got neighbors one and six
so that works now what about the eight
how about here because then we've got
the one four and the three adding up to
eight now what about the nine well here
would be a good place for the nine
but that looks promising
because i can see where to put the ten
the ten can go here because we've got a
four and a five and a one okay now i
think it'll be easy now because we
continue that thread we'll put an 11
there now the 12
there's going to be a clever place to
put the 12
here the 12 is a bit of a nuisance
because we really want to get down to
using the 13 and the 14. we have to
so to speak place the 12 in a way that
won't interrupt us because you can see
that we have a 13
square here the six and the seven and
now now we've got a one six and a seven
so we can put the 14 there and we can
put the 15 there with the one and the 14
and we can put the 16 here now i
carefully provided stones labeled
through 16 because i knew that 16 was
the best we could hope to do
the two undergraduates who came up with
this puzzle worked this out they proved
that you can't do better than 16 with
two starting stones because because you
could put the starting stones in
different positions but that's the
optimal position to put them in is that
where you where you placed yes yes what
makes this an interesting challenge is
that in fact you could put the starting
stones anywhere you want in the whole
world
so if you were writing a program to
search for this you could say for you
know x1 from minus infinity to infinity
from but of course you don't do that you
say without loss of generality we can
put the first stone there and then
there's really only one good place for
the second stone but then the number of
possibilities increases initially it's
an impossible sounding problem but in
the end we
can do pretty well so that's the
solution with with two starting stones
all right so and it's 16 and
we know a few more terms so we actually
know
only six terms and the six is sixty and
three is twenty-eight
four
is thirty-eight
and five
is forty-nine
that's all we know
we don't know seven no one has been able
to work it out
and maybe it's because nobody has really
tried hard do we know the stone
configuration for three four five and
six we obviously do we know one yes it's
not necessarily unique here for example
are the configurations for four stones
we you put the starting stones the brown
stones in these places and then you work
it out and eventually you can get up to
38 there and with six starting stones
that's the starting pattern and you can
get to 60. now one thing i was expecting
you to ask me brady is how do you know
it's finite maybe if you're really
clever you can put down the two and the
three and the four and five and go
around in this in a spiral
and get
very large numbers well that's not
possible
and i will prove it i can also give you
a lower bound i can show you that you
can do at least
this well
this is a construction of andrew harroid
look at this look at this construction
we're gonna put down a one a brown stone
here leave a gap there and put a one
here these are the two brown stones and
then we can put a two here then we can
put a three
a four a five and a six there and then
he said let me have pre-placed a one
here
if we do that then we can put a seven
here and then we can put an eight and a
nine and a ten and an eleven there
very cunning
and then we're going to put a 12 there
in a minute so let us have pre-placed
another brown stone there and then we
can get 12 13 14 15 16. and there in a
minute we'll go 17.
so each
each brown stone
buys us five more steps
when we put down that brown stone we
were able to add 12 13 14 15 and 16
and here we got five and here
we got five so with n
starting stones n brown stones this is
not the best you can do but it certainly
shows
that you can get at least five n minus
four because each time you add one more
brownstone so here with two brown stones
we went up to six and if i put n equals
two two brown stones five times two
minus four is six three brown stones we
went up to eleven and this thing's going
in a straight line it's going in it's
not gonna twist it back on it no it's a
zigzag
so
we just do in a zigzag like that and
keep going
it's a very simple-minded construction
and i wouldn't be at all surprised if
some ingenious person viewing this can
come up with something that does wrap
around itself and give a much better
lower bound but at least we know it
grows linearly five n minus four
now what about in the other the other
direction can we put a limit on how many
you can get
and
after that i need another piece of paper
is there any limit to how many you can
get if you've got three brown stones
what's the maximum possible you could
ever hope to get
you might think you could get infinitely
many and the way i think of this is it's
a kind of a mountain climbing problem
you want to get as high as you can but
in order to get to that height you have
to build steps up the mountain to get
there to get to height 31 000
up at everest you've got to have steps
in the mountain that are labeled with
all the numbers down to one and the one
being what any one of the huts i think
of the brown stones as huts brown being
a good color because the huts are
usually down on the ground and the white
of course corresponds to the ice where
you're cutting the steps the snow feels
that you're ascending
so let's suppose
you could get to a very high point and
this argument from robert kibbitz says
let's look at a really high point let's
call it
h
it's a square where we got very high up
how did we get there well it's got eight
neighbors how could you get a hundred to
get a hundred you must have had some
pretty big numbers around it you could
have had for instance an 80 and a 20. we
could have had a 50 a 49 and a one a one
would be a hut a a brown stone i want to
argue
that there must be
um a fairly small stone somewhere in the
neighborhood if there's a one so much
the better but there there has to be a
stone
around it
which is less than or equal to 50.
in fact less than or equal to 49 but
never mind if if we've got an h here one
of these stones i don't know which one
is less than or equal to h over two
because if all the stones around it were
bigger than h over two we wouldn't we'd
get a number bigger than h here so one
of the eight
at least one of the eight has to be at
most h over two
a neighbor of this
well look at the neighbors of that
the neighbor of this h over 2
one of them must be at least
at most h over 4
say there
and the neighbor of that must be at most
h over eight
and so after going
after going d steps
from this high point there must be a
square with at most h over 2 to the d
but if we go far enough
that's got to be a 1. it's got to be a
1. the small one
you get to the high point has to have a
neighbor at most
h over two a neighbor of that has to be
at most h over four that neighbor of
that most h over eight each time we go
one step further away we can divide by a
power of another power of two so for
instance to have a concrete example i
was going to use everest it's a little
easier if i take 65 000. suppose
we could get up to 65 000. 65 000 is
just less
than 2 to the 16 which is six five five
three six so i i've picked a number here
just a bit under two to the sixteen and
so following this path you're always
taking the smallest neighbor we will
eventually get down to a one in at most
15 steps so from here to here so if it's
six five five think that means within a
radius of 15 there's a one there's a hut
and one of our starting things
all right so now
let's suppose that we could get to 65
000 using just three ones
let me prove that's impossible
so let's say we have our
high point here
six five
sixty five thousand twice as high as
everest and
within a square of side fifteen within a
square around it
of size 31 by 31 there has to be a heart
somewhere
so a brown
starting stone let's suppose we were
able to get to 65 000 with just three
starting stones here's a starting stone
here's a starting stone
and here's a starting stone and we know
that somewhere within distance 15 of one
of these three is the 65 000 so if i
draw the squares
around it of size 31 and around here
size 31 and around this one of size 31
inside one of these three squares of
size 31 is our high point is our point
higher than mount everest the 65
000 is within one of these three squares
that's what i just proved but
that's going to be impossible because
not only do we have to get
sixty five thousand we have to get
all the numbers up to it we have to get
all the numbers in these squares
one two
well we've got the one we have to get
two three four
all the way up to six
four nine nine nine before we can get to
the top it's not going to work because
inside this square
there are only 31 square stones less
961 less than a thousand so we've got a
thousand squares here a thousand squares
here a thousand squares here total of at
most three thousand squares on the other
hand we have to get sixty five
stones to get up there so it's a
contradiction so you can't do it with
three stones three stones are not enough
to get to 65 000 you can't create
branches that come out of the squares no
because if there was a stone at 10 000
there still has to be um
a one within
10 000 divided by what
the appropriate power of two they all
have to be within the squares of side 31
centered at the three hertz everything
we do has to be within these
these three squares
so what does that mean for our upper
bound so our upper bound yes so what
this actually gives if you do it
properly is about n log n for the upper
bound but
robert kubitz
fine-tuned the argument and um taking
care of what happens around the hertz
the small numbers doing that counting
more delicately and he proved in fact
you can't get more than 714
and if you have n huts and brown stones
the highest you can get is 714 times n
so we know you can't get arbitrarily
high
but that initial sequence you showed me
went up to six went up for six terms yes
and that wasn't 714 times n no it's just
an upper bound he's he he's just proving
that you you cannot hope to do any
better no matter how clever you are in
fact you can't do anywhere near as well
but it's just
it's just a theoretical upper bound
the answer is zero what about a three by
three if we put a black queen here it
attacks all the squares except these two
so we could put a white queen here we
could put a white queen here too but
we'd have two white queens and we could
not put two black queens so the numbers
have to be equal okay all you can do is
one one of each color